foreign
heat is driving extreme rain in Northern
India where unusually heavy monsoons
have caused deadly flooding and
landslides
[Music]
the residents of this Village can only
watch in horror from their rooftops as
Tree Trunks and mud surged down the
street
elsewhere in the country Rising Waters
have destroyed Bridges and Roads
stranding thousands
scientists say climate change is driving
more severe weather everywhere including
here in New York state
a slow-moving storm dumping rain causing
flash flooding more than 20 million
people across America's Northeast now
under flood alerts they're calling this
a 1 000 year event
it's only the second time ever that the
National Weather Service issued a flash
flood emergency the last time was
Hurricane Ida
my friends
This Is The New Normal
Zaragoza in Spain experienced
unprecedented flooding just a few days
ago residents caught by surprise as
their roads turned to rivers
at the same time temperatures keep
climbing the World Meteorological
organization saying the planet has
probably just experienced its hottest
week ever and new research suggests
Europe's hottest summer last year caused
over 60 000 heat-related deaths we will
have a a very high likelihood of
increased and more frequent heat waves
um and if we don't address the problem
of adaptation we will sadly continue
every year
um to see reports of high mortality and
morbidity related to heat
the impact of climate change on humans
increasingly apparent as emissions
continue to rise along with weather
extremes Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News